i
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy ángela gómez y los acompaño para
seguir abriendo los caminos de discusión
en torno a la invasión rusa sobre
ucrania hoy se realizó la primera ronda
de negociaciones entre kiev y moscú en
la frontera con belarús unos diálogos
que no dan por ahora signos de cambiar
las direcciones del conflicto bélico y
que sucedieron en el mismo día que el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
firmó la solicitud de entrada de su país
en la unión europea bajo un
procedimiento que llamó especial tienen
posibilidades los diálogos escuchemos o
para comenzar los comentarios rusos tras
el encuentro y la solicitud de
excelencia
puedo decir que cada hora de conflicto
trae nuevas víctimas entre los soldados
ucranianos
así que definitivamente estamos
interesados en alcanzar un acuerdo tan
pronto como sea posible pero esos
acuerdos deberían beneficiar a ambas
partes
hacemos un llamado a la unión europea
para una adhesión inmediata de ucrania
vía un nuevo procedimiento especial
estamos agradecidos con nuestros socios
por estar con nosotros pero nuestro
objetivo es estar con todos los europeos
y lo más importante es ser iguales y
donde a bud medir el análisis y el
panorama en europa del este lo tienen
nuestros invitados se conecta desde
ciudad de méxico la doctora maribel
contreras suárez coordinadora de la
licenciatura en negocios globales de la
universidad de iberoamericana y desde
viña del mar chile está a guillermo
holzmann analista político
internacionalista y también profesor
universitario ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en el debate con sus comentarios y
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook instagram y twitter estamos
como france24 guión al piso ese y ángel
ago efe 24 que desde mi cuenta personal
les recuerdo también nuestra etiqueta
numeral el debate efe 24 esperamos sus
comentarios y comenzamos
empezar preguntando el nivel con las
buenas noches y con el saludo que sin
resultados concretos pues ya terminó la
primera jornada de negociaciones entre
ucrania y rusia en la región fronteriza
de belarús que puede salir de estos
encuentros
puse saludarte angela sin duda muchas
gracias por esta argentina invitación me
parece importante entrada resaltar que
en lo personal me hubiera gustado que
fuera un territorio en realidad neutral
donde se estén llevando a cabo estas
negociaciones sabemos que hoy a suiza
pues ya no se mostró tan neutral pero me
parece mucho más neutral que bielorrusia
sin embargo qué bueno que se inicien
este tipo de diálogos para ver si esto
logra bajar la escalada de esta invasión
militar sin embargo pues sabemos que es
muy difícil en un par de horas en días
que se resuelva lo que menos no se han
logrado resolver por lo pronto te puedo
decir que es lamentable lo que estamos
viendo pero más lamentable ver que estas
líneas rojas que cada vez se escriben y
se tiñen en color más rojo y más grueso
pues son por posturas totalmente
opuestas no sea por un lado entender
y visualizar lo que tanto se ha dicho
que es esta expansión de la otan y por
el otro lado pues que es hay una
violación al derecho internacional por
violentar la soberanía de un territorio
entonces me parece que al punto al que
ha llegado hoy esta situación esta
invasión con las afectaciones e
implicaciones financieras económicas
comerciales energéticas pero también
humanitarias hace cada vez más difícil y
mucho más complejo que entonces se pueda
avanzar en un diálogo donde ambas partes
se dan y que queden conformes entonces
me parece que hoy en día está este
cuestionamiento y este planteamiento de
si a lo mejor pudiera haber la onu u
otro foro o un país
tercero donde no sea parte de este
conflicto y si pudiera ser neutral sin
embargo pues sabemos a nivel por los
acercamientos que hubo entre selenski y
entre el lukashenko que pues finalmente
fue la única posibilidad que tuvieron
para los diálogos que empezaron con
desplazamientos desde la jornada
guillermo quisiera preguntarle con un
saludo por supuesto para usted también
usted cree que puede haber efectos
positivos aunque sea en un mediano plazo
porque mientras que avanzan estas
conversaciones pues eso no ha detenido y
lo aclaró muy bien rusia la escalada
militar
exactamente estamos en un proceso de
negociación urgente que tiene un
imperativo de pueblo era de alto al
fuego luego lo mejor de esta negociación
que según de esta economía se ha
realizado el día entre ambas
delegaciones es que al menos hay una
reunión programada lo peor que podía del
pasado es que esta reunión no fuera
debut y despedida y eso dejará solamente
otro tipo de instrumentos de la parte
militar como en medio de la
confrontación entre ucrania y rusia y en
el volcamiento mayor que ha tenido la
europea por lo tanto de un día que acá
lo primero es que ayer la última reunión
se conoció por fin cuáles son las
condiciones actuales de
ucrania y de rusia respecto llegamos a
los temas a abordar en un eventual
proceso de negociación que puede llevar
al alto al fuego retiro de tropas y
definir la situación de la zona del
donbass etcétera por lo tanto creo que
es una buena noticia lo último
importante hay a nivel de alguna forma
también lo decía es el tema de que
bielorrusia tiene que ser capaz de
demostrar quién es efectivamente neutral
y eso hasta ahora todavía el deber recto
a todo ello por lo tanto creo que acá se
abre una ventana de oportunidad una
ventana oportunidad donde las acciones
de ucrania no se dejan digamos que nos
dejan estar como es la petición de
ingreso a una europea ni las de rusia
con respecto a la posibilidad real real
de mantener la presión bélica sobre icfh
y sobre las operaciones militares en lo
que arias mire usted estaba mencionando
crimea y es que precisamente en esta
jornada vladimir putin conversó otra vez
con su homólogo manuel macrón sobre un
acuerdo y rusia dice que solamente se
podría lograr si según los términos de
rusia hay una neutralidad de ucrania que
esté desclasificada y desmilitarizada y
además habló de la legalidad desde una
crimea rusa usted cree que esta es una
posibilidad sobre la mesa que después de
una anexión en el 2014
finalmente en 2022 crimea sea reconocida
internacionalmente como parte de rusia
si es una posibilidad concretar men
particularmente en el caso específico de
crimea es una posibilidad de la
negociación política diplomática e
incluso
con el soporte militar que eso conlleva
pero a su vez también es importante
establecer de que más allá de que se
puede acceder línea no es no es no va a
ser los centros y va a ser el resultado
de varias otras condiciones que va a
tener que instalarse en esa en esa
perspectiva el tema de la
desclasificación
particularmente es un tema donde las
evidencias nos acompañan a rusia donde
efectivamente a ucrania no ha dado
tampoco evidencia en contrario y donde
donde en distintas posiciones que son
más complejas porque llevan que ver con
el corazón de ucrania y con la
estabilidad democrática que no ha tenido
que danny a nuestro antiguo de los
últimos años y a nivel de clasificación
de ucrania sigo insistiendo sobre el
término porque sigue vladimir putin
utilizando esa referencia que nos
devuelve la segunda guerra mundial y
además nos recuerda una época en la que
moscú jugó un papel muy distinto al
papel actual y como usted dice no le
queda a vladimir putin como decía usted
guillermo
hay que vivir y regresar al pasado no es
decir putin está formado a querer tener
una composición de un mapa como lo era
inclusive antes no de la segunda guerra
mundial está cerrado no reconocer lo que
sucedía después de la guerra fría está
firmado a regresar siempre al pasado
este término de neón así pues me parece
que en lugar de sumar resta para poder
avanzar en un diálogo
está este acr que es tradición que él
trae de poder venir y trazar sus líneas
en este mapa pues me parece importante
que el tendría que tener más claro que
lo mejor en otra directriz y no
utilizando esta terminología que pues
sólo tiene una connotación negativa pues
eso en realidad no insisto no ayuda como
tampoco insistir en que estos grupos
separatistas pues de la región de
donbass en su momento pensábamos que era
la única zona que le están interesando a
putin ahora vemos que pareciera que es
en todo el territorio de ucrania y esta
terminología
indica que no usa como el hecho de que
ayer ya también anunciara el tener
listas las armas nucleares pues sólo
recuerda esa época de la guerra fría
donde se utilizaba esta teoría de la
distracción de tener listas las armas
aunque no se utilizaran me refiero a la
parte nuclear y por eso es que hoy te
comparto angela territorio pero cada vez
estoy más convencida que estamos
viviendo una segunda guerra fría 2.0 que
ha sido y pues sí enfatizado desde hace
más de un año y medio porque a la luz de
lo que estamos viendo pues cada vez se
están dividiendo
occidente con con rusia y pareciera que
ahora está poniendo o existiendo una
nueva cortina de hierro que atravesaría
al territorio ucraniano angela bueno
pero en esta que re fría la diferencia
es que hay armas y hay fallecidos de
ambos lados
guillermo volver a crime volverá a
ucrania un estado vasallo podría ser uno
de los objetivos de vladimir putin
bordearla por el sur pero luego también
vladimir putin tendría que mantener ese
control y hacerse a su paso según el
teorizan algunos
así hasta moldavia usted qué opina
porque hay quienes dicen que ocupar
crime ocuparán ucrania por completo pues
sería una operación demasiado costosa
para el kremlin o sea no solamente
costosa el tema extra en que hoy en día
no hay modelos económicos alternativos
salvo el liberal si rusia está en una
perspectiva no liberal me en torno a
cómo aborda el tema de ucrania y
consideran ocupante ucrania como pueda
sentar su posición en ser reconocido con
resto del mundo es exactamente lo que no
va a suceder
primero porque rusia no tiene la
capacidad económica de mantener un
esfuerzo bélico por mucho tiempo de esta
naturaleza allí particularmente en una
crema y que está al lado de europa
podría de problemas y como no políticos
económicos militares bueno de una serie
en todas las dimensiones posibles y eso
ni ese esfuerzo no no pareciera hacer
todo indica que el esfuerzo hoy día de
rusia a esta expansión que pretende
redimir putin y que se debe
efectivamente por la divinidad inicial
que el que tiene el apoyo
a 300 granos en definitiva ahora rusia
está particularmente a la dine putin
enfrentado con postales de ahí en
adelante de la mejor forma posible y
todo parece indicar que el principal
objetivo es tener completamente el
control sobre crímenes un reconocimiento
a mantener una influencia permanente
sobre el donbass
quizá sea iba a ver toda la discusión
respecto a si se se pide que se
reconozca la independencia de esas dos
provincias aquí a su vez también donde
tenemos que mantener una posición de
privilegio con las potencias en términos
de ser reconocida a pesar de que rusia
tiene un producto interno grupo similar
al de italia entonces liberó que hoy día
la situación de denuncia y buscar el
mejor punto de negociación pero no creo
que esté pensando y que una posibilidad
de ocupar ucrania y después moldavia y
después aunque tarde largo ver a los
países bálticos como sevilla ya
prácticamente una hipótesis mucho más
expansiva que puede aceptar en
convención de acuerdo y llevarlo a cabo
no hoy en día sobre todo y quisiera
preguntarle ahora usted a nivel de los
costos de la guerra hasta cuándo puede
rusia contener las sanciones sabiendo
que vladimir putin tenía clarísimo
cuando entró a la guerra que habría
castigos internacionales pero también
que había manera de disuadir los eau por
la dependencia energética
así es ángela me parece importante que
puntualicemos que obvio putty sabía de
incremento de sanciones o que ya de por
sí había sanciones a raíz de esta
versión de crímenes del año 2014
entonces de ahí seguramente tuvo que
estar preparando a su país preparando
las arcas preparando reservas de oro
también preparando alimentos y sobre
todo entrenando y estando listo y
preparado para poder accionar el botón
rojo porque al final del camino sus
intereses geopolíticos y geoeconómicos
pues son abismales y ccoo hasta cuándo
puede aguantar rusia pues me parece que
esta decisión la estarán tejiendo y
cocinando el interior del kremlin para
saber cómo es que en esta guerra de
resistencia que es la estrategia militar
que está utilizando putin estará
aguantando entre menos dure es mucho
mejor por el impacto que esto tendría su
economía
y en términos financieros y todo lo que
hemos venido viendo a la luz de las
últimas horas sin embargo pareciera que
pues está del lado de putin decidir
hasta que un aumento está dispuesto a
llevar no sólo su país una guerra sino a
esta terrible afectación que se está
dando en la región de europa pero con un
impacto mundial porque sabemos que ante
esta interdependencia económica lo que
suceda en rusia o en ucrania tiene un
impacto ya inmediato en todo el mundo la
hiperconectividad que se ha generado por
la globalización pues permite que los
países justamente lo estén sancionando y
entonces estamos viendo que lo están
estrangulando en diferentes áreas para
que justo tome esta decisión de estar
sobre la mesa negociar y de ahí ver si
es factible llevarlo a una retirada de
tropas de ahí que si jinping se
pronunció a favor de que se sentara
justo a negociar y pareciera que hoy en
día has oído únicamente escuchar a la
voz de su gran aliado implícito como lo
es china ángela
y sin embargo baja la fuerza del
invierno y conforme esto pasa pues se
hace más difícil el avance de las tropas
que sabemos solamente se habrá utilizado
aproximadamente un tercio de las tropas
rusas hasta el momento en este asedio
que se realiza sobre ucrania guillermo
hasta cuándo va hasta la unión europea
los miembros de la onu buscan más
sanciones estados unidos anunció
completamente anular las operaciones con
el banco central ruso
a es una sanción que realmente puedo
detener la guerra guillermo
el si yo creo que la sanción estos días
es que se han colocado sobre la mesa
particularmente las restricciones al uso
del código swift para la transacciones
en las transferencias de divisas y
particularmente un golpeo muy directo al
que afecta la liquidez inmediata digamos
de rusia en el corto plazo y tenga
enviarlo a plazo pero también a eso se
ha sumado al bueno pero aplicar el
código swift no son bancos
internacionales los que definitivamente
hacen eso recordemos que código surge de
una asociación de bancos donde hay
obviamente gobiernos pero que eso no era
usado normalmente en en el paquete de
sanciones otros países como irán por
ejemplo ao corea del norte pero también
becas como tenemos el derecho de que
empresas multinacionales como el caso de
google o del aporte que ha hecho león
donde más al ir a colocar los satélites
a servicios de ucrania para poder
aminorar el impacto negativo de los
ciberataques son cuestiones novedosas y
al lado de eso la fia de unidades y
kevin consenso sobre las medidas que ha
tomado un nuevo europea transformándola
en un acto principal distinto de eeuu
y elementos relevantes donde
probablemente lo no europea va a tener
más capacidad de presión sobre putin
para que digamos aceptó un esquema de
negociación y acepte también una salida
que sea un rosa para putin el mundo no
puede funcionar sin rusia y rusia no es
similar a corea del norte en
consecuencia acá el tema de la
negociación no solamente tiene que vivir
como sagan sabes las tropas de ucrania
como para las hostilidades como se
vuelve a una foca pero aún cuando eso
signifique entregar crimea completamente
pero a su vez también significa dar una
salida honrosa al adversario de tal
forma que no quede acorralado ni
signifique un riesgo que hemos inmediato
o obtenido en torno a lo que podría
eventualmente realizar más allá de lo
que más se computen dow en el poder
entre el medio su legitimidad y el
término del apoyo que pueda tener luego
de esta situación de neutralidad a nivel
sirve el mecanismo de la asfixia
económica
latte que apenas hace un mes saca
publicar un libro técnico de vender que
habla sobre el arma económica es decir
que él está a favor de las sanciones
económicas pero también una guerra de
gas y también el tema de las
ciberguerras me parece importante
visualizar que hoy estamos viendo en
diferentes aristas que la manera de
estar acorralando asociando con estas
medidas bancarias de la salida del país
en este sistema de pagos internacionales
pero también la parte deportiva donde ya
no permiten que se realicen partidos de
fútbol y obvio eso un día en proceso no
no no es una sanción no pero al final de
cuentas es estar tomando todas las
aristas el tema del gas es muy
importante porque aunque de entrada
pareciera que a rusia le conviene que
sigan subiendo los precios del barril
del petróleo por encima de los 100
dólares donde ya hay aquí mora estimó
que puede llegar hasta los 150 dólares
al final del camino en esta
interdependencia comercial pues no nada
más a los precios sino cómo afecta
también el ingreso y el acceso de los
bienes de consumo los servicios todo lo
que tienen que comprar funciona ahora al
estar fuera de este mecanismo se está
aislando y lo mismo sucede con el hecho
de ya no permitirle sobrevolar el aire y
el espacio europeo de canadá de eeuu a
sus aerolíneas también es una manera de
ir acorralando es decir estamos viendo
esta guerra híbrida totalmente inédita
con nuevos frentes con muchas vertientes
donde seguramente estaremos viendo que
se estarán continuando y adicionando
nuevas medidas pero ojo que como todo
puede ser un boomerang no es tan fácil
nada más decir aquí está la lista y lo
implemento mañana porque habrá empresas
también estadounidenses habrá empresas
también europeas que colateralmente
puedan sufrir un daño al implementar
estas medidas entonces el tema también
por ejemplo de los granos ucrania más
rusia aporta 25 el trigo que se consume
a nivel mundial entonces estamos viendo
que también ya el mar negro está
teniendo sus implicaciones por los
buques rusos que tenían que atravesar
por ahí y cada vez estamos viendo cómo
el mundo se suma para estar a favor de
la paz y de una u otra manera en algún
momento se tendrá que arreglar a putin
para que
insisto ponga sobre la mesa si sus
líneas rojas pero que se transformen a
negras y que hay un punto de equilibrio
donde él no sienta que su seguridad está
siendo amenazada y que tampoco los
países que son miembros de la otan
no muevan sus fichas para que rusia así
lo cierta como ya lo hemos visto este
fin de semana con suecia y compilar ya
que cada vez tocan más está este punto
tan débil y está frágil como es el tema
del hotal entonces es un gran reto
angela ver hacia dónde dirigir las
conversaciones para que pueda ver un
punto de equilibrio donde ni un lado ni
el otro
lo que llamamos
acá en méxico que es poner el dedo en la
yaga pero bueno cuánto tiempo va a
necesitarse para eso a nivel porque ya
llevamos aproximadamente 8 años de
guerra en el donbass de hablemos de la
anexión de crimea desde el 2014 y aquí
hay una guerra que apenas comienza la
unión europea ya está diciendo que de
pide a sus estados miembros recibir a
los refugiados al menos durante tres
años es decir esto no es algo que va a
terminar pronto y por el otro lado pues
volodymyr selenski hoy presenta un
documento firmando la solicitud de
entrada de su país en la unión europea
bajo un procedimiento que él llama de
especial qué tan factible es a nivel de
la candidatura que sea presentada ahora
que hay un conflicto bélico en
desarrollo no se logró en 2014 antes de
la caída de yanukóvich y bueno han
pasado tantos años desde esto y ucrania
ha sido como una suerte de tira y afloja
entre occidente y rusia
así es y coincido totalmente contigo
angela es difícil que ucrania logre con
este mecanismo que llamo el presidente
es el esquí de un mecanismo express para
que logre ya su ingreso a la unión
europea no cumple con las condiciones
económicas para que cualquier miembro
nuevo solicite el poder ser parte de
este bloque económico obvio le urge para
poder disponer de fondos que a través de
la comisión europea son administrados
para poder brindar asistencia
humanitaria sin embargo sabemos
perfectamente que es a través del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas de
los refugiados donde se tendrá que
administrar esta nueva crisis
humanitaria que ya está comenzando a
verse porque aunque las cifras nos dicen
que más o menos al día de hoy van más de
200 mil ucranianos que están huyendo de
su país se estima que en algún momento
en corto plazo esta cifra pueda subir
hasta los 5 millones de personas donde
la responsabilidad no sólo está
recayendo en rumanía o polonia sino que
ahora toda la unión europea tendrá que
resolverlo pero difícil que se logre en
un plazo inmediato que ucrania ingrese
cuando en otras circunstancias no
cumplía con los requisitos como también
lo es es muy difícil y muy lejano que
pudiera ingresar a la otan entonces
estamos viendo que por un lado ese
quisiera un escenario diferente
en ucrania para poder accesar a más
mecanismos y más apoyo de occidente como
es la activación del artículo 5 de la
otan que establece que cualquier
agresión a uno de sus miembros pueda ser
expansivo al resto ucraniano es miembro
del hotal y es ahí justo el punto de
quiebre de la conversación donde tendrá
que reiniciarse retomar hasta cuando
angela no lo sabemos entre más pronto
mejor avance el diálogo pero si te puedo
decir que la brújula y cada vez la veo
más distante para que puedan llegar a
una solución pacífica en un corto plazo
mire primero una precisión porque
mientras que nosotros hablamos las
cifras se van creciendo hoy ya se
reportó que son más de 500 miles de
refugiados por la guerra en ucrania una
cifra que sigue creciendo
y mira sobre la candidatura pues turquía
lleva 20 años siendo candidata y todavía
no ha podido entrar a la unión europea
sin embargo guillermo quisiera
preguntarle un poco viendo los matices
de este tema en el caso de que ucrania
fuera aceptada para una posible
candidatura eso podría marcar la
diferencia de alguna manera en la forma
en que occidente le brinda apoyo a
ucrania usted cree que esto podría
cambiar los términos de la guerra y así
podría cambiar el término de la guerra y
yo me ha contado que a nivel concierto
de equipo europea va a considerar que
históricamente la petición que hace un
gran ya un euro que ha logrado avanzar
en acuerdos concretos y acciones
concretas se meta con últimas 72 horas
en muchos aspectos que habían quedado
suspendidos en varios años atrás y con
muchos debates europeas en consecuencia
logró que hoy día está viendo a través
de ucrania una una ventana de
oportunidad para un posicionamiento
estratégico a nivel mundial que le sirve
no solamente en el caso de rusia sino
que también para poder negociar con eeuu
y continua lo principal
le escribí como firme tras solicitud no
se le haya ocurrido sino porque hay
negociación y de acuerdo a
conversaciones que van a orientar en ese
sentido aprovechando la situación que
está viviendo hoy día digamos ucrania no
por casualidad de que las declaraciones
europeo y díaz hayan sido tan
contundentes en el apoyo grande en la
unidad de la unión europea y también en
lo que se refiere a la ayuda militar y
humanitaria y de mediano y largo plazo
además comprometido entonces acá yo creo
que hay algo que está mucho más avanzado
lo que nosotros pensamos y se le aquí
solamente está iniciando el trámite de
la formalidad para eso debate no claro
pero es que la guerra está sucediendo en
el patio de al lado de la unión europea
sin embargo guillermo usted ve razonable
que el bloque haga una excepción y cree
algo tal como ese proceso de candidatura
exprese que está pidiendo selenski
el sitio lo yo lo veo razonable del
punto de vista de estratégico de la
unión europea lo veo muy razonable
porque escribía colocan un freno
definitivo para digamos a rusia aún
cuando después de ucrania no ingresa lo
está porque lo más probable es que
ucrania no vaya ingresar la otan pero
sin que la europea consolidó en lo que
es su mecanismo de defensa pro este tema
que estaba independiente de hace varios
años en un debate muy intenso a su
interior y donde efectivamente hoy día
cuando alemania anuncia que va a colocar
el 2 por ciento en los medios su
producto interno bruto para el armamento
defensa claramente no está pensando
solamente en alemania está pensando en
el conjunto de los países europeos que
también parte las conversaciones que ha
llevado adelante con una realidad que
ucrania nave jesucristo que es peruana
tiene elementos que son responsabilidad
no solamente de rusia sino que también
hay temas de varios años con respecto a
otra en eeuu a que la que hay un tema
que es mucho más complejo detrás de todo
ello pero que hoy día para cuando se le
quiere cómo superar esta etapa de
conflicto
extraño dramático que estamos viviendo y
en definitiva hay soluciones políticas
pero que tienen que ver también con otro
equilibrio en el modo pues claro pero y
le tengo que insistir con el tema porque
usted no cree que aceptar una
posibilidad solamente una posibilidad de
que ucrania hiciera un proceso para
entrar en la unión europea pues sería
vista como una provocación mayor para
vladimir putin estamos hablando de que
ya el tema diplomático pues se quedó
rezagado hace rato y ya estamos hablando
de una invasión que tiene curso esto no
le daría incentivos a vladimir putin e
para caer con más fuerza y con más
rapidez al sobre ucrania
putin ya hizo el esfuerzo máximo de
invadir un clan y han de poder tomar y
como su control no solamente son las de
donbass sino que ahora el resto de
ucrania
el tema de pueda aceptar justamente a
ucrania en la unión europea sin lugar a
dudas va a ser ya sea como miembro pleno
como miembro temporal como miembro del
estudio pero va a haber una fórmula en
la cual ucrania va a quedar circle a una
europea o inserta dentro del propio no
europea y en esa perspectiva no se está
pensando si eso va a provocar más va a
incentivar más en una respuesta las de
rusia eso sería mostrar una debilidad
estratégica de parte no europea al
respecto a rusia y acá estamos hablando
netamente lo europea y no de eeuu y eso
es un detalle que no resulta ser menor
dentro de lo que se está discutiendo
detrás de lo que está y el tablero de
guerra que tiene hoy día ucrania sobre
el mundo y ya que hay yo insistiría en
el hecho de que la idea de que solamente
se ingrese a la unión europea vamos
asegura que ingeniera aún ninguna línea
de negociación mucho más amable con dura
en todo caso con russian el futuro más
allá de cómo se resuelva o como se
establezca una hoja de ruta de
negociaciones y solución de
controversias córner entre rusia y
ucrania radio de conflicto bueno y ahora
a nivel quisiera volver a ver sobre un
tema que ya le había preguntado más más
al inicio de este debate que usted nos
había mencionado y es que putin en este
domingo incluyó dentro de sus mensajes
la palabra nuclear eso sin duda tuvo que
haber disparado alarmas en todo el mundo
alarmas en la otan o pues porque ya
estamos hablando de otro tipo de
conflicto de un tema de devastación
total
usted cree que esta es una manera
indirecta de disuadir a eeuu para que
siga manteniéndose firme y la otan es
sigue manteniéndose firme pues por qué
es una amenaza de no se metan porque si
no esto se puede volver mucho más grave
y ya es una pelea pues de la que yo ni
siquiera le puedo decir qué medida hay
totalmente contigo angela porque muestra
de ello es que como es que ellos mismos
suben el vídeo donde él pide que lo
grave o sea no es una conversación
privada confidencial que se haya
filtrado sino que es una manera a través
de sus estrategias de propaganda para
hacerle saber al mundo hasta dónde están
dispuestos sin embargo es una estrategia
militar
enviando este mensaje de capacidad
nuclear donde ellos están listos que se
utilizó inclusive durante la guerra fría
pero ya hablar de una escalada así me
parece totalmente
abismal la diferencia la capacidad
militar que tiene un cráneo frente a lo
que tiene rusia entonces me parece que
se queda en un lenguaje y en un léxico
de estrategia en cuanto a su
comunicación política para llevar a
occidente a que como sabía que iban a
sentarse a la mesa a negociar xavier a
partir de qué punto iban a empezar a
negociar de ahí
es decir si analizamos finalmente es la
parte rusa la que ha estado manejando y
maniobrando la agenda de negociación de
mucho hacia abajo entonces ahí es
justamente el tope donde se ha subido la
parte rusa para empezar en este diálogo
de negociación que seguramente las horas
pasarán como si fueran siglos pero donde
todavía nos tenemos una claridad de qué
es lo que va a pedir ahora y útil a
cambio de la retirada de las tropas eso
es como la gran incógnita al menos hay a
mis ojos sobre entonces antes estaba
dispuesto a con que nada mande
garantizarán ucrania será que es el
mismo punto de negociación donde está
dispuesto a partir de ahí negociar o
será que ahora ya se han ampliado sus
peticiones angela usted qué opina de
guillermo tiende la situación a empeorar
porque entre otras cosas no ha logrado
putin y capturar quiere por ejemplo
porque si lo que hemos visto y lo que ha
salido a relucir en los análisis de
france mente de las últimas semanas es
que este conflicto ha avanzado en
materia bélica más lento de lo que
esperaba putin
exactamente y eso tiene que ver no
solamente con la resistencia que ha
colocado el ejército ucraniano o el daño
que le ha hecho a su línea de apoyo
logístico y de entrega de suministros a
todo lo que es el
ejército ruso que ha ingresado fran ya
lo que llama la atención es que no ha
hecho endesa todo el material que ir que
logró desplegar alrededor de fronteras
de dos plantas y no quiso entregar
solamente una parte de eso a su vez
también digamos ha sido muy concreto en
términos de no hacer un avance que sigan
digamos digamos contundente para poder
tomar izquierda y eso nos lleva a pensar
de que está usando al ejército con les
sacan con esa con ese poder de fuego
para lograr una mejor negociación
posible una negociación que se salió ya
los parámetros iniciales que tenía su
propia planificación y que ahora están
respondiendo al al día a día o al nuevo
contexto escenario que está viviendo a
raíz de la respuesta ucraniana de la
unidad de occidente para poder sancionar
justamente a rusia más allá lo que se
había hecho anteriormente a otras
naciones y que efectivamente el costo
para footing cada vez se va aumentando
aumentando más la decisión ha venido de
putin es acaso un romper el jarrón en
términos de entrar con todo agua ucrania
y actuar como lo ha hecho antes por la
vía de hechos consumados hasta ahora lo
único hechos consumados que tiene es el
apoyo a la independencia de las dos
provincias en el donbass pero no hay más
que eso si quiere agregar otro hecho
consumado más y es la captura de kiev
donde eventualmente significaría que la
muerte o el secuestro a la pensamiento
del presidente se les quita su estado
mayor a definitivamente estaría
colocando un tema que para occidente
sería muy difícil de aceptar y que
rompería inmediatamente las
negociaciones y no dejaría al resto del
mundo por muchos ratos buscando una una
puesta una una línea de salida para que
para todo ello y qué es lo que nadie
quiere guillermo disculpe pero es que
nos quedan menos de dos minutos de
programa y quisiera rápidamente por
favor les pido no más de 30 segundos que
finalicemos este debate con la misma
pregunta que comenzamos y ese tienen
posibilidades progresar los diálogos en
ucrania guillermo rápidamente con usted
hoy en día se ha demostrado que hay
voluntad de proseguir con el diálogo y
es sin cimientos piensa posibilidad del
diálogo hay posibilidad de negociación y
un resultado favorable para colmo y a
nivel la única manera que pueda avanzar
este diálogo para poder llegar a un
acuerdo es haciendo presión y delaware
por parte de la comunidad internacional
donde en realidad rusia rea que pierde
más siguiendo que en cuanto a la
retirada pudiera ganar más en términos
no sólo de levantar en tres canciones
sino inclusive en una cuestión de sus
peticiones en el ámbito geopolítico
angela pues muchas gracias a los dos por
lo que nos aportan en esta en este
debate y en esta posibilidad de análisis
en mientras que france24 continúa
haciendo el seguimiento constante de la
invasión rusa a ucrania eso es todo por
el momento nos vemos próximamente en
france24
[Música]